mr. young when you were at call me Neil
Jesus Christ when you read when you
would start when you write boy to stock
meal okay thank you when you were at
Woodstock you've got you got ticked off
in other words I think the commercialism
of Woodstock freaked you out you were on
stage with crosby Stills and Nash and
young and the cameras are in your face
they're making like the [ __ ] cameras
okay they didn't have to be right there
that was stupid they didn't have to be
on the stage their cameras hello
use your zoom [ __ ] there were too
close while they were on the stage and
when we were playing music and there's
this jerk standing there with some other
guy with a you know following around and
getting on the stage like wearing black
clothes like you couldn't see them come
on get out of here did anyone discuss
that with you ahead of time no they
didn't so you said to the camera guy at
Woodstock he'd get the [ __ ] out of my
face and as a result you're not in the
movie we just see crosby Stills and Nash
yeah I love that movie the way they say
it if you listen to when they introduce
crosby Stills and Nash
you can tell wait a minute did I say the
full name of the band there
[Music]
you can tell that they caught if you
listen it's it jumps they had to take my
name out and use the other two names in
the right order